hello belief nation I started a mentor
me series to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully by spending a little bit more
time with them
some of how they think their values
their beliefs their mindsets their
attitudes seeps into us to help us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're going to look at the Dalai
Lama and some of his most inspiring
speeches mentor me Dalai Lama and as
always guys as they're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below reports around it so
other people can be inspired as well and
when you write it down it's much more
likely to stick with yourself as well
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
his Holiness the 14th Dalai Lama is the
spiritual and temporal leader of Tibet
people and exiled government in 1959 he
dramatically escaped into exile and
established the Tibetan government in
northern India
the Dalai Lama has dedicated her life to
the promotion of world peace to this
ends he was awarded the Nobel Peace
Prize in 1989 religious harmony and the
preservation of Tibetan culture are also
two of his main concerns throughout the
last 50 years he has traveled around the
world sharing his wisdom and Buddhist
teachings
thank you I usually describe happiness
instead more satisfaction happiness not
necessarily some pressure pleasure sort
of experience but neutrals of experience
can bring deep satisfaction in your
experience what makes you truly happy
I believe see the peace of mind that
peace of mind also we succumb firstly
from haughtiness that I can reduce it
feeling towards other and also reduce
this sort of disgust I always I never
consider myself as something special if
I consider myself something different
from you like I am Buddhist
Oh even more I'm his holiness Dalai Lama
Oh
or even the sequence either I am Nobel
laureate then actually you create
yourself as a prisoner
[Music]
I forget these things I simply consider
I'm one of the seven billion should be
we are mentally emotionally intelligent
we are saying what is human value money
oh yes very important sometimes I
jokingly is telling the Buddhist
audience but we'll intervention you
usually use you decide one Tibetan
special sort of mantra that is Oh
Moneypenny home
so we recite sometimes we little bit
hurry then you see we decide or
Moneypenny or money borrowed then money
or money money money money so that
sounds looks like money money money
money money right so maybe dollar money
dollar money or found money bond money
like that
so buddy of course what I think value
and of course all these external
versatile facilities this value of the
things good but all these
- might physical comfort not mental
comfort if you have plenty of money then
some kind of satisfaction independent
level or I have a lot of money that
solution actually because we notice
among the bulimia plenty of money but as
a person very unhappy person or don't
worry robbery anxiety lot of suspicion
lot of jealousy as a person dealing
money fail to bring in a piece bill
money bring me more suspicious more
uncovered more worried anyone who truly
believed if you have money
everything can solve everything
then you get rid from the processor
section the second Alisha money can
bring some friend but that essentially
friend of money not friend of being
yourself the old fortune go like that
you become richer decision you found
more friends
then when your orcid a your fortune goes
like that then these
also I think disappear
even you want to telephone they may not
answer this
so these and are not changing to your
friends but a friend of your money as I
mentioned earlier Ragan challenge that's
best opportunity to tell your with the
old wisdom your internet in this new
challenge these potentials overlap
exchange comes then these potential
become a more alert as a practitioner as
a Buddhist my daily prayer right one
beginning early morning these days about
3:30 I wake up then initially I set up
my mind
oh yes for the day my body speech mind
delicate to well-being of other that so
and more difficulties more heavier
responsibilities have this authority
feel all this good opportunity to serve
some like that a financially and this is
some problem and due to English and do
push off cycle of to too narrow-minded
and frustration and variance problem
wide awake long-term it brings more
determination more power in order to
keep inner peace
passion lately makes differences very
important because self-centered for the
person very sort of cherish in oneself
only ones have so the reflection of that
feeling use word III like that so that
works nothing wrong but the real
attitude here just think oneself so can
go only oneself then even tiny problem
appears unbearable in your attitude
think others well-being then with others
is infinite so tell more about others
well-being your mind open widened then
your own problem appears not significant
insignificant same problem same tragedy
can be much different how you see it
this angle you can see something
variability from this angle
oh okay that often does it happen
therefore the compassionate attitude
really widened so one's own problem then
not much sort of seriousness so that I
can make differences and the rest of the
people really feel me as a politician
furthermore bad politician and I feel
sad or cunning read a cunning liar
politicians dint of course no problem
the problem a son says and the good
person sons a bad person that doesn't
matter some of my own motivation for
thinking is honest since a that's it
that's important that's simple Buddhist
monks actually but that is it thought
don't care what others are saying
one say too much praise then at that
time should think or I also have the
critics and then one says it did not run
cruising then you should think or some
people praising me the so doesn't matter
too much though because of the pay much
attention these things are silly then
age to four
I lost my country the last fifty years
now still not a problem lot of sadness
lot of heartbreaking news during this
period money failed to bring is a sort
of also Trevor consolation consolation
stuff but then only thing which bring in
a piece is my own inner value a passion
and spirit of forgiveness and also
realistic attitude these things brings
in a lot okay but my physical health
also this inner value really is it
positively smiled on my health or my god
health health one specialist is
described me as a young patient then I
told him I'm not young now more 73 years
old so then he says yes I know your age
73 was 33 but your body looks still like
60 60 old so he described as a young
patient
[Applause]
so that shows my mental peace in a sort
of strength I think really makes
differences about body element so we are
saying same you mean therefore I want to
share you ultimate source of your happy
life as a happy mental state is within
yourself that I too should know then I
think the best method to avoid fear or
regret at the time of death is while we
are in life our time our energy must
utilize meaningful way serve another
[Music]
decisive most profitable drug way of
meaning of usefulness one's own survival
even animals also can do
but for service to other is something
unique about human being I think bondage
a mother and child or offspring have
formed the bond between mother honest
even other animals also have but there
are sort of that kind of closeness
feeling short period but we human being
because of intelligence that kind of
feeling we can prolong whole our life
extended travel ah so certain other
people helping other people as I think
very very proprietary our interaction
strength or human ability we have such
an ability
so then utilize that ability Allah in
the most appropriate way or most
appropriately is seven other people then
at the end you feel no regret I done my
best some useful so meaningful life now
and come on oh sorry
sad but no regret hurry bottle to the
century later bartender century much
positive change to place fighting world
yes there is a lot of crisis a lot of
bad things but also is a lot of good
things and yet we have been told to fear
anyone in everyone a reality he says
that is impacting one of the
fundamentals of human happiness so we
are social element therefore friendship
is very essential friendship comes trust
fear and trust go contradiction more
fear there cannot develop trust we fear
how can the presumption I think
eventually we can we can develop more
deeper velocity of other experience
about online maybe somewhere please now
on I must make a new person same body
but you person thank you guys so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love
to know what did you take from this
video that you're going to immediately
apply to your life or to your business
what was the most important lesson that
you learned please leave it down the
comments below I'm super curious to find
out I also want to give a quick chatter
to John Thomas the simple programmer
John thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book through one word and
doing that awesome review on your
YouTube channel I really really really
appreciate it it's a good book
definitely check it out it's called your
one-word by Evan Carmichael again fellow
youtuber so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon